Time make sense in small pieces,
but when you look at
huge stretches of time,
it's almost impossible to
wrap your head around things.
So let's start small with
minutes, hours, days.
You probably spent the last 24 hours
mostly sleeping and working with some
coffee in there somewhere.
Please watch less TV.
Now let's look at 2013
relatively unnoticed.
Hitler's bodyguard died at
the age of 96 Wallen in June.
Edward Snowden started the NSA
scandal moving back a base.
The 21st century is still pretty young
and largely shaped by the attacks on nine
11 that ultimately led
to the 30 rock wall.
Oh and Facebook and smart
folks took over our lives,
but we just getting started.
Let's back up further.
The 20th century has seen
its share of conflicts too.
After two devastating world wars,
the Cold War lasted for almost
the whole second half of it.
An average human lifespan covers most of
this stuff as well as the birth of the
Internet and the beginning
of the information age.
The oldest living person on earth is
currently miss how Alcala who was born in
1898 which means that her birth was closer
to Napoleon ruling Europe than to the
current day.
The last 500 years of human
history brought enormous
changes to our lifestyles.
Industrialization gave rise
to new ideas like communism.
Farmers became workers and knowledge
became easier to distribute.
The theory of evolution changed
how we saw ourselves and the world.
We live in a wall in a few hundred years.
The 15th century was very eventful.
Columbus is discovery of America
and the fall of Constantinople.
Mark the end of the Middle Ages. People
in the Middle Ages were super into war,
over territory and religion,
but the black plague was far more
efficient than war killing every third
European in six years
arriving in the common era.
Let's take a look where we came from.
Our current century is tiny
and 2013 is barely visible.
This is recorded human history.
The pyramids were
constructed 4,500 years ago.
The peak of the Roman empire was
2000 years ago, so to the Romans,
the pyramids were as old as
the Romans are to us today.
History starts with writing,
but what happened before that?
About 12,000 years ago,
the agricultural revolution took place.
Mankind began farming,
which gave rise to the existence
of cities and larger communities.
The dominance of the human species over
planet Earth really started here 90,000
years ago. Neanderthals and
humans coexist. Europe, fun fact,
this is roughly the time period a modern
space craft would need to reach the
nearest star.
Hello Sapiens,
the modern human evolved
200,000 years ago.
Looking at all of human history, what we
call a d seems pretty small, doesn't it?
6 million years ago,
our ancestors and the modern chimpanzee
shared a common ancestor for the last
time and for 2.7 5 million years.
Stone tools were all the rage,
a mere 65 million years ago,
the age of the dinosaurs and
it in an enormous explosion,
which paved the way for
the rise of mammals,
but the dinosaurs roamed the
earth for an incredibly long time.
Over 165 million years that so long that
it means that t rex that lived at 65
million years ago is closer to seeing a
live Miley Cyrus concert than to seeing
our life stegosaurus animal life on this
planet started 600 million years ago.
The earliest animals were
fish and other small,
simple sea creatures then came insects,
then reptiles and finally
around 200 million years ago,
mammals joined the party.
Life itself began much farther back.
3.6 billion years ago
before any animals appeared,
there were 2.4 billion years when
life consisted only of tiny microbes,
countless at single cell
bacteria for 3 billion years.
All life on earth was
invisible to the naked eye.
It's hard to understand how single celled
organisms could develop into complex
life forms like fish or slots.
The answer is time.
A whole lot of type 2.4 billion years is
a lot of time to work with 4.6 billion
years ago, the son was born from
the remnants of a giant explosion.
60 million years later earth
formed in those early years.
Frequent bombardment by comets and
asteroids supplied the earth with large
oceans and a moon to send spaceships too.
But as far as the whole universe goes,
our solar system is pretty new.
13.7 5 billion years ago,
the universe was born and
600 million years later,
our own galaxy formed
from billions of stars.
But what was before the big bag?
The truth is we don't know that
yet and maybe we never will,
but we gave it some colors, so at least
we have that and there you have it.
The past. Now let's take a look
at what we know about the future.
And roughly 1 billion years,
the sun will be so hot that life
on earth becomes impossible.
The death of the son, 4 billion years
later marks the end of the service system.
Okay? So no more soda system.
And what happens after that?
A few trillion years from now,
stock reduction will cease and one day
the last star in the universe will die.
The universe will turn dark,
inhabited only by black holes.
Long after the last black
hole has evaporated,
our universe reaches its final stage.
Something called heat death.
Nothing changes anymore.
The Universe is dead forever.
Now you're feeling some
pretty weird feelings right
now, aren't you? We are too.
It's only natural.
The good news is this is all far,
far away.
The only time that actually matters is
now that cute girl you like Oscar out
time is precious.
Make it count.